okay thank you all right well welcome
everyone to today's meeting of the local
Planck cabinet advisory participating
and those who are watching on the
livestream if members have technical
difficulties during the meeting please
contact the Democratic services officer
on call who will attempt to assist you
and today's Democratic Service Services
Officer is Emily Kennedy and her number
is five double seven zero four six
it will also be at the top of the chat
thread for members if you need it but
those of you watching the council's
YouTube stream please follow the
instructions below the video if there
are any issues with the live feed and
asked participants when you're not
speaking please mutual microphone this
minimizes background noise will help
everyone in listening to proceedings
microphones must only be on if the
participant has been granted permission
to speak it's a game my Commissioner to
speak please very briefly indicate on
the chat to the right side of the screen
and I will then make a note and go back
to you once the person speaking is
finished with everyone please ensure
that their mobile phones return to
silent and they're not used to make or
receive phone calls while the meetings
in progress please also refrain from
checking emails or conducting other
business and ensure that you're in a
quiet room free from distractions for
the duration of the meeting please note
that this meeting is being live-streamed
for members of the public the meeting
will also be recorded and will be
subsequently broadcast on the internet
so please can I ask the members of the
advisory group to confirm that they're
present in the meeting when I read out
your name I will ask for the attendance
of any counselors are participating in
order to speak under council procedure
20.1 separately at the moment I'm not
aware of any so if you could just
indicate that you'll hear councillor
Bailey I'm here good evening Thank You
Chancellor fellows yeah yeah councillor
Garner I'm here to a cute cats the
Huxley
perhaps he doesn't seems appear which is
quite striking she's in the same house
as many years hello I'm here sorry Thank
You castle I'll speak as the scoby yes
I'm here
that's the Scot here
thank you and counsellor right right no
counselor rights okay are there any
other counselors present the wish to
speak under counsel procedure rule 20.1
speak now or forever hold your silence I
don't think there's anyone else here is
there okay so apologies I've not been
notified of any apologies declarations
of interest does anyone have an interest
to declare in the items business on the
agenda this evening nobody speaks up so
we move on into the presentation to set
the context for the local plan review
work which will be given by mr. Verrill
the strategic planning manager mr.
Farrell Thank You chairman
good evening members I hope you are
going to better see presentation you
should be seeing it now
okay um I don't think members can see it
I we can say yeah okay I'm not quite
sure what's happened there hold on let
me try again
I'm going to try and load me from
scratch again
No okay I hope you're seeing it now
sorry consume their agent okay thank you
I'm purpose of this presentation is to
set out some background and context to
the local plan review process
I'll only be speaking for about 15
minutes and I'll be covering a quite
general level why we have a local plan
something about the current local plan
strategy I'll cover quite briefly the
local an examination inspectors report
because that's been considered by
committees something about the local
plan review an update process and
importantly the role of evidence
gathering in that process and then very
briefly the local development scheme
which is the work program that we have
to produce as part of this process and
obviously if I can all answer questions
at the end there are a number of quite
important reasons for having a local
plan in place the main reason is that it
provides certainty for everybody
involved in the development process
about where development is likely to be
acceptable and where it's not and the
type of development we would want to
support so it provides a starting point
for planning applications it also helps
to guide investment both private and
public and supports bids for government
infrastructure funding we are currently
involved in to funding processes one is
called the health the housing investment
fund which is a fund to help overcome
infrastructure constraints on housing
sites in particular and the other one is
was called the MRN process the main road
network process of which the a 28
through Tamar Gate is part of the
network and for which there is a current
beat to government being led by KCC and
I could I'll come back to that a bit
later
local player needs a statutory
requirement but as you can see there are
some good reasons for having a local
plan in any event so just very briefly
this is in very brief terms the local
planners strategy as it is in the draft
that's been through the examination and
which is going to committees we have to
produce a Kedar diagram the idea is to
try and set out the strategy so that
people can see the reason that we've
come to the different decisions I hope
you can see the little red cursor on the
screen so if I just very briefly explain
some of the things on the map so some of
the constraints include the area around
the coast which is all designated
nationally and internationally as a
wildlife area the area's here the sort
of stipple blue are all flood risk areas
there is a tiny bit in the center of
Margate as well but obviously the air is
out on the once in channeler are much
more extensive these green areas here
are the green wedges and it difficult
the shonky diagram but obviously we do
have a number of conservation areas and
we do have about 2,000 listed buildings
as well so there are the things that
have to be taken into account
so the strategy broadly has been to look
at brownfield sites including old
industrial land sites within the urban
areas but part of the plan strategy
includes urban extensions at Burton here
West Gate south of Margate hearts down
shop and then around westward area here
and just wish to Ramsgate which is the
site known as Menston green this area
here is Madison Business Park and the
brown line is what's known as the inner
circuit so this is a scheme that was put
together again with KCC's involvement
to try to reduce congestion on the
existing over the network to link the
new sites but to link them with westward
in particular and Madison Business Park
and also the wider road network so just
on quickly on in termination and
inspectors report the examination
hearings completed in July last year 16
hearing days we had about 46 pages of
questions from the inspectors which
would discuss that that examination we
received a report in March and published
in April the inspectors main conclusion
was that the plan is sound and legally
compliant subject to the modifications
they are suggesting I staged the best
thing it's it's actually quite strong
recommendation because what they're
saying is that without those
modifications the plan is not sound
having said that they did support much
of the hell the the strategy the housing
numbers the the key sites employment
sites infrastructure Environment Policy
tourism policy so although there are
quite a lot of modifications they are
quite technical modifications rather
than changing the strategy that's in the
plan as you know committee report was
considered by Capitol on 23rd of April
and is due to go to overview and
scrutiny panel next week I thought it
might be worth covering very briefly
some of the main modifications so
there's a new policy on review of the
plan which is obviously pertinent for
this meeting a new policy on Madison
Airport my nco process also a change to
the trajectory for housing provision so
this reduces the requirement in the
first five years but it is balanced by a
higher requirement in the later years
so the overall housing requirement
doesn't change they've simply recognized
the fact that there are key interest
projects that need is coming forward
before we can start delivering at a
higher rate there are also some changes
to the other policies I've mentioned
there they are slightly more minor
changes but in particular draw your
attention to the Gypsy and travel
accommodation members will be aware that
there's been a lot of discussion and
debate about my over the last couple of
years and one of the things that the
inspectors put in place was a new policy
to cover the identified needs so just
quickly on the update itself members
will remember that a couple of years ago
the Secretary of State intervened in our
local Plan process and at the end of
that process he sent us a direction at
all and one of the things that we are
required to do is complete a review of
the local plan within six months of its
adoption now I appreciate we haven't
adopted to plan yet but six months it's
an incredibly tight timetable to do a
review process and so it's felt it's
worth beginning work now so that we've
got that little bit more time to
consider the achieved so the purpose of
the review is to assess whether a full
update of the plan is necessary or if an
update is necessary what that scope is
and obviously that's the role of this
group so the purpose is to look at the
plan as its adopted and to see what
needs updating what's changing and how
we address those things the review
process doesn't require this group or
the council to make instant decisions in
that six months about exactly how we're
going to deal with those issues simply
to understand the scope of them and to
explain how we're going to approach them
how we how we approach addressing those
issues so there are a number of things
that the inspectors raised for us to
look at in the review
implications of climate change there are
there is a particular set out in the
local plan but this is a quite
fast-moving agenda and no doubt we will
have to review some of that need to look
at the provisions of the banners they
like to Manson Airport members will be
the way I no doubt that the DCO
decisions been made until July but
during the review of the plan we will
need to look at what that decision is
and how we respond to it the third one
is really about checking that we've got
the right housing requirements against
the government's what they call standard
methodology tid of the provisional gypsy
and traveler sites which I've briefly
covered already and then to make sure
we're compatible with the latest cutting
guidance so just a couple of things in
relation to review the government
guidance says that we need to take into
account changing circumstances affecting
the area any relevant changes to
national policy and if the housing need
figures change so some of the things
I've just mentioned there's an
interesting piece of guidance that says
that we should have proportionate
relevant and up-to-date evidence to
justify a decision not to update
policies now clearly we if we adopt the
plan as anticipated then clearly the
plan is quite up to date and we will
need to look at whether much of that
actually needs to change but officers
have already started to just take a very
quick view of the policies as they
appear in in that draft to see which
ones are likely to need updating
obviously we will bring that to the
group for discussion in due course part
of the other things in guidance is that
it says that strategic policies have be
prepared over a minimum 15-year period
so that suggests that we may need to
extend the plan period beyond 2030 one
to twenty thirty five or six or possibly
beyond again is something for discussion
but then as part of the review process
we have a duty to cooperate so as we
start to develop what we think the scope
of an update is we do need to discuss
that with Canterbury Dover KCC Irish and
Town Council's
and there are other bodies like Natural
England and the environment vironment
agency and rather strangely the Colville
authority though every time we contact
them for consultation tell us they're
not interested but we still have to
contact them because they are one of the
statutory bodies just one other quick
slide on the review process this is just
again an extract from the guidance what
can we consider when determining whether
any of our policies need updating
housing delivery performance whether we
can show that we've got a five year
supply of housing land and those of you
who have been on planning committee will
no doubt I've heard in Livingston refer
to this on numerous occasions how our P
sites are being delivered how we are
performing an appeals annual monitoring
so the strategic planning team does a
lot of monitoring each year on what
development is taking place housing
employment development retail to see
what the current trends are and whether
sites are being delivered changes to
higher tier plans well that there aren't
many higher tier plans than the local
plans because of the way the system now
operates but clearly people like natural
England Highways Agency the southeast
leppe and others are producing plans and
obviously we need to be clear that we
are sort of working with them as we
develop our plans plan making activity
by other authorities where this is
specifically carried over can't reassign
me ahead of us in terms of reviewing
their plan would obviously we all need
we do have good
contact with our rescan colleagues and
so we'll need to continue that and share
our review work as we go and we need to
look at things like economic changes
that potentially could impact on plan
viability and also any other priorities
that that may change during the period
of the plan there's got a lot to cover
and as I say six months is quite a tight
timescale and that's the reason really
where we why we thought it'd be useful
to start a little earlier and start to
pool to get the work on there I
mentioned earlier the importance of
evidence and you can see this quote
there from national guidance preparation
and review of all policies should be
underpinned by a relevant and up-to-date
evidence so the key things for us in the
first instance are to look at the
housing numbers through the standard
methodology and we've already
commissioned work to begin on that which
we hope could be shared with the group
of an early stage to look again at
employment land supply and allocations
and retail provision again already
having some discussions with KCC about
that because obviously the current
circumstances have changed the way
people approach retailing and it's a
little early to know whether that's a
permanent shift or a temporary one and
I've mentioned they're also transport
modeling which KC's here involved with
of what we call the call for science so
when we know what provision for housing
we need to make and employment and and
in our case traveler science as well the
general approach is to issue a call for
sites to see what land is genuinely
available to meet that need and at the
end of this process we have to produce
what's called a local development scheme
it's actually a work program for the
local plan for three years the one
some slide areas the ones currently
published it has to be agreed by cabinet
and because obviously we've had
intervention from Secretary of State we
need to keep them on board and make sure
they're aware when our new local
development scheme is published so
that's a quite a flying overview I am
more than happy to answer questions if I
can thank you Jim
thanks agent I think that's quite quite
a comprehensive overview if members want
to ask questions perhaps they could
indicate in the in the text box I'll
start with a couple of questions
I mean you referred obliquely to the
Cobie 9c in crisis I mean obviously
there is the potential for that so to
reshape quite a lot of things in the way
the society interacts and it's something
that we're gonna have to factor in and
how feasible is that going to be in the
short term because really people don't
know you just don't know where things go
and the other thing you might want to
expand a bit on is obviously we haven't
had the outcome of the mountain DCO I
think we might get it on July the 10th
that seems to be the suggestion now but
even then there could be a further
period of uncertainty if that subjects a
legal challenge which I think it's quite
a lot of noise around here might be
subjects for legal challenge from either
side depending on the outcome so how is
that kind of complicated what we're
trying to do yes thank you Joe and
though they are too quiet complicating
factors I suppose at the end of this six
months all we will be able to say in
terms of the local development scheme is
that we know that these are issues that
we need to address coded 19 you know we
we hear a lot of discussions about how
things will change and what will change
and how much it will change and I have
to think to some extent we are going to
have to wait and see what happens
you know as restrictions are lifted and
as people try to resume their lives and
sort of normal way as it were but I
think it will be something we'll be
wanting to speak to
mhm CLG about because they will be
perfectly aware that this is a big
uncertainty for everyone so I think
that's something we just have to keep
under review as we go you're right it
could cause quite a lot of uncertainty
in terms of of how we approach certain
topics as far as the DTO is concerned
yeah
10th of July is what's being touted as a
decision and again you're quite right we
could be in for a long haul before a
final final decision is made from the
local pound perspective obviously if the
DCO is granted we all need to start
looking at things like air quality
aircraft noise consoles whether there
are no transport implications
potentially even housing implications
and public safety zones so there's quite
a lot there if the DCO is granted
if the Distasio is not granted then
clearly we will have to consider the
future of the site as part of the review
but you're quite right that either
decision might be subject to additional
review so I think we will have to
proceed on the basis that whatever comes
out of that process we have an
understanding of what we'll need to do
okay thanks I think if you if you could
stop presenting there that would it
makes it easier for members to see the
meeting see you thank you I've got
councillor garner and then councillor
fellows thank you yeah I did I did have
one question but you've actually hit on
a couple of things that have made me
think of another couple of questions but
my initial question was was about the
time scale so we got six months review
or is that mean there's a six months
from the adoption so this is like a
preamble to the star of that six month
review yeah we have to have carried out
the review within six months of adoption
the soda party
we've just got a little bit more time to
consider the issues yeah okay thanks
and these you were talking about Kovac
19 and the impact there's this this plan
is gonna be at least a 10 tip is a 10 11
year plan so here we ought to be
thinking about contingency planning for
any future pandemic which means there's
obviously quite a quite a risk that
there would be another one some stage in
the future and we need to be ready for
that yes I'll agree with that
they certainly the local government
information union I think is produce
some guidance on how planning might
start to look at those sorts of issues
what it made money might mean for public
spaces so that yes you're quite right in
terms of resilience for those kinds of
events that is something we will need to
look at as part of that process
okay I'm sorry love just coming back to
it to Menston my guests yeah we don't
know what the results gonna be so but it
can really only go one of the two ways
on it although it's approved or isn't so
we can start looking at what we would do
in each of those options ready for the
decisions made right so we going down
that which we've already started or
we're going down the other work which
we've already started so we'd only wait
until the decisions made before we start
planning for it yeah I think that's
quite right we does give us the
opportunity to look at what the
implications are either way and to start
to think about how that might affect the
plan yeah okay thank you
that's it thank you Thank You councillor
fellows yeah thanks so I'm just want to
ask about the six-month would there be a
grace period from the adoption then
before any planning applications that
will be submitted by developers on
allocated plots so I mean if we get if
we decide we want to move plots around
or find other plots without with the
planned applications be held for six
months for there before they're approved
that's my first question
I don't think we'd be in a position to
do that we have to deal with County
applications in the time scales that we
have I think the issue here is that we
have submitted a plan we consider to be
sound and the Inspectorate have found it
sound so it would be quite difficult I
think to Road back from the sites that
have been allocated because they are
they are sweats that the Inspectorate
have accepted and are recommending that
we include in the plan yeah I appreciate
I mean we found a brown field site for
per se for 2,000 houses we can't move
2,000 houses from grade one agricultural
land onto a brownfield site I think the
issue will be is when we do the housing
numbers what what changes there so if we
need to find additional housing for
example it may be that whatever other
sites we can find would be needed to
meet that requirement as well sure I
think I think the issue is that because
those sites have been through an
examination and the inspectors have
found them sound it is quite difficult
to sort of come back from that position
really sure and you said about extending
the plan obviously this plans been oh we
have another local plan for nine years I
mean you're saying in 15 years time we
might have to have another one so I mean
how far can we extend this plan could we
go to 2040 so we've got 20 years of this
plan yeah I just say I think it's 15
years as a minimum or 15 years is what
it should be so that does give you the
opportunity to consider whether actually
a longer plan period may be suitable
okay that is possible yes okay I think
we probably all hope that the next local
plan doesn't take quite as long to
prepare as from get through the process
as this one yeah so don't think that's
been satisfying to anybody cares lebay
Lee
and you a mute yourself Castleberry
it appears not being here is councillor
Bailey yeah I keep losing rhenium the
drop-down screen keeps disappearing and
I can't get onto it
my question to Adrian was about the
neighborhood plans how do they tie in
are we is that all part and parcel the
review yes I mean what we try to do is
to work obviously there are I think
there are four neighbor the plans
currently under preparation at different
stages the two sets of plans don't have
to be completely identical but clearly
it makes sense if we can produce them
sort of in parallel or at least so that
the plans are sort of supporting each
other so that's what we've we try to do
I don't know whether we're going to get
any more neighborhood plans but I know
that there are particularly for at the
moment and we are working with those
groups as closely as we can in terms of
the relationship to the local plan
from me then I mean can somebody come
forward with the neighborhood plan at
any stage yes they can
it's a bit like the old when we had
county plans are called structure plans
and where they would produce a plan and
obviously ideally if you've got a
structure plan and then the local plans
all followed neatly along that would
have that that makes everything very
tidy but it doesn't tend to happen like
that and it's the same with neighborhood
plans so it's really a case of
neighborhood plans just seeing where the
local planning processes act and trying
to feed into that but yes they could
start one any time okay councillor Scott
so counselor Scott you need to come out
of the chat function I understand all
that said yeah which one mute yourself
okay it doesn't allow that's happening
counselor Scott so as any other members
want to ask a question in relation to
the presentation and only as Mike
suggested could we have a copy of those
slides please yes of course yes okay all
right then so we've got another meeting
scheduled I think um the next thing to
consider really is the work program and
it's a pool what we might be discussing
there you've got some ideas on that for
us mr. bill mr. chairman right ticket
that members I've just not at the
presentation yes I think if anyone
disagrees that they've noted it them
like they could indicate now thanks
Charles
okay so you have a copy of an outline
work program I believe this is only
indicative it's just to give you an idea
really of how we might cover the ground
before we have to submit the or publish
the LDS so working back from publishing
the LDS in December hopefully we are
aiming to look go to cabinet in November
and that gives us the opportunity for
five five meetings of this group in that
time so what we would hope to do over
that period is to bring you some of the
scoping work we've done in relation to
government guidance bringing evidence to
you as soon as it becomes available to
talk about what rotation we need to do
with neighboring authorities and others
and so how we do that and the idea would
be to present you with a draft committee
report in October that sets out the
local development scheme so for your
discussion before it went to cabinet you
know them so that's that's the plan I it
is quite a general plan it's quite
flexible we can move certainly move some
of those items around and obviously it
gives you as members the opportunity to
input your concerns and ideas into that
process as we go along so it's quite a
formative process okay the members have
any car no councillor Scott wants to
come in and we'll give him an
opportunity when we've dealt with this
item but and the members have any
comments about the work program for the
advisory group
doesn't look as if they do caster Scott
I know that your comment your question
probably relates for the previous item
but in view of that the technological
issues I'm quite happy to let you ask it
now yeah many thanks appreciate that
yeah and it's like a laptop issue so
we're going on the old phone and it was
just really quick one then was back on
the the last item it was just in
relation to and apologies of it isn't
relevant for this particular meeting the
infrastructural star the themes
especially with Southern Walter I mean I
would just speak for my ward
specifically and I don't know that's
dumb thing to do but I mean apparently
the drainage side of things something
Walter have said some occasions that
it's not something they can actually
accommodate and we have been known to a
subsystem drought so I mean that was
just something I saw want to bring to
the table before this particular
discussion well I can tell you what
happened to the local plan process that
we've just have been through in terms of
the examination we had to produce an
infrastructure delivery plan which is on
the website and I can certainly give you
a link to that at some point if you're
interested and that tries to cover
everything so it covers utilities
highways it covers education it covers
health so what it's identified in there
yeah is what are considered to be the
needs and that's information has come
from those bodies directly so they
certainly haven't flag to us through the
process that there's a water supply
issue we know that there are certain
sites that have got slightly tricky
sewage connection issues that need to be
resolved but I haven't suggested to us
that there's an issue in terms of water
supply if does that answer your question
he does for the time being so many
thanks and that one fake it okay now do
members have any questions about the
world phone any comments about the work
plan or are we happy to adopt that move
forward doesn't look like anyone has any
any comments at this stage okay so do we
need to note that report Charles yes mr.
chairman I think it's nothing the okay
so that that report is noted in this
anybody dissents and I think that
concludes the savings meeting
thanks very much for everyone for
attending